wie geht es jetzt weiter für aktivisten
und für die polizei in dieser sehr
angespannte situation wir schalten mal
live in den hambacher forst zu dörte
hausten geschiedene knollen dingeldey
sie ist gerade dabei in 15 meter höhe
ein neues baumhaus zu errichten wegen
der schlechten handyverbindung benutzen
wir natürlich das zdf dosen telefon
dörte
ich hörte wie wollen sie dann der
räumung noch entgehen hallo hallo also
das netz ist hier ganz schlecht
ich glaub ich steh im wald wer ist
überhaupt nicht lustig nrw macht sich
gerade voll zum büttel der braunkohle
aber wir bleiben hier no matter what
mein freund der clemens und ecke wir
leben jetzt schon auf diesem baum seit
du clemens lange schon bestimmt schon
über 20 minuten ja zu hause ja der
clemens macht uns gerade noch ein salat
aus laub und aston martin ist für mich
diesmal ohne kefer
wenn euch die polizei da nicht vorher
runter holt na ja die sind schweine
system gibt ja nicht mal zu dass es um
braunkohle geht dafür sich zum stück von
rwe machen wissen sie mit welcher
begründung die hier an ihre sind
schwerwiegende verstöße gegen geltendes
verordnungsrecht vor die baumhäuser
hoffen die nicht über erforderliche
rettungswege sie wurden entgegen der
einschlägigen brandschutzrechtlichen
vorschriften errichtet sind es leider
kein witz wir fliegen raus wegen
brandschutz
und jetzt muss man natürlich wissen
baumhäuser stehen ganz oft bäume und
bäume sind teilweise der gehört auch zur
wahrheit aus holz und hat die natur
einfach nicht zu ende gedacht unter
brandschutz sie sich zum sorry ich jetzt
wegen brandschutz klar steht der staat
kein spaß
scheiß auf umweltschutz aber wenn der
brandschutz fehlt dann kommt die
abrissbirne überall heute nachmittag an
sein hier tragen den flughafen ber platt
zu machen aber der clemens und wir jedem
nicht oft ergab jetzt ein architekt
beauftragt wir bauen hier oben ein
baumhaus das sämtlichen deutschen
bauvorschriften entspricht
hier ist mal der entwurf des programms
gerade die st
richtig schön hier morgen
das ist angelehnt an den tausch von
christian wulff in hannover
er ist sogar barrierefrei aber wichtig
ist uns ja dass der protest weiter
friedlich bleibt ja gut das hat bis
jetzt aber auch nur fast geklappt
die kollegen wurden hier auch noch mit
fäkalien beworfen und mit urin gespritzt
der final angriff seien laut protestler
ein versehen
das war ein versehen der clemens hatte
uns ein eichhörnchen erwirkt und nicht
richtig durchgebraten und dann ist sie
mal die sind mal lerchen passiert
clemens echo alter patzer herr welke ich
muss jetzt leider schluss machen da
kommt der amazonen boote der bringt den
69 zoll flachbildfernseher wörter
hausten geschehene klingen aber damit
hamburg
[Musik]